Lillian is with us in Pasadena Texas hi
Lillian how are you hi hi babe thank you
for having me
sure actually yeah so I have actually
done your course a couple of times and
so I'm finally ready to take it
seriously this time and so I've been
working for about three years now
I'm single and I make about two hundred
and fifty K a year and I have almost
I've actually done pretty well I pay it
off pretty much three cars my during
this time and then a student loan I have
two student loans remaining and pretty
much all of my credit cards or fund so I
don't have any that I still have two
more student loans that I need to pay
off unfortunately I lost my car in
Harvey so I had to take out and use a
new car loan to pay off that car and
then you make two or fifty thousand
dollars why'd you have to take out a car
loan well because I didn't have
mobilized loans at that time and one of
the reasons why my my income increased a
little bit is because I became a partner
what my company so that's kind of my
projected income gotcha so what do you
do I'm a position right okay so you
haven't been making 250 for the whole
time then no today looking forward
though you make 250 you've made some
mistakes in the past you've been on and
off the wagon so to speak and now you've
looked up and the only thing left is how
much in student loan debt I have about
sixty sixty three thousand student mom
and then my car loan and then another
thing too is I kind of give away a lot
of money
so like I pay for a lot of help them
pretty much paying my mom's mortgage and
then
like helping her to pay certain bills
and things like that and then I give
notice that I give a lot and offerings
and things I went well it was her
question so my question is is trying to
figure out the best best way to mobilize
my income in order to pass the loan
because my goal is the FAFSA student
loan in the car which is about 80,000 by
the end of this year you're the car the
car is 80,000 is to the car and the
student loan together 80,000 yeah the
karna student loan together has done all
of that you have left no I took out a
business loan to become a partner and so
that's an additional two hundred and
thirty five thousand so I want to hurry
up and try to pay off these funds I can
become more aggressive of paying off
that line okay so you make to it let me
summarize you make two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year you're
completely out of control with your
money you have no freakin idea what
you're doing
oh you actually do know what you're
doing you just haven't bothered to
control your impulses and you have an
amazing amount of money that you make
two hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year but you have eighty thousand plus
two hundred and thirty was it instant
and and so so 310 makes you debt-free
yeah here's what you here's what you
should do but you won't do okay mm-hmm
you should quit paying anyone elses
bills and you should get on beans and
rice rice and beans and you should pay
off a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
a year for two years and be a hundred
percent debt-free two years from now but
there's nothing in anything that you've
told me that indicates you're going to
do that nothing because you were doing
all these silly things that you know are
silly and you're just doing them and
then giggle and you're you know you're
gonna have to really grow up about this
because you're gonna be one of these
stupid broke doctors if you rest of your
life if you don't and they're stupid
broke doctors everywhere they're worse
than stupid broke athletes they really
are and so you make so much money that's
why it's stupid you're making $250,000
a year and you're in debt up to your
eyeballs you have to do something about
this so I'm gonna pay for you to go
through Financial Peace University one
more time this time it better stick you
know it's time you know you have an
amazing intellect but you're gonna have
to add wisdom to your intellect you
couldn't have gotten to where you are in
the medical field if you didn't have a
strong intellect and making partner as
quick as you made so you've obviously
got amazing skill within your career so
now let's add wisdom to that and
maturity to that and you know let's
let's land your personal life in the
land of grown-ups you can't pay
everybody's bills you're broke and
deeply in debt broke and deeply in debt
people don't need to pay other people's
bills so hold on I'll have Kelly pick up
we're gonna get you back in Financial
Peace University for one more year
membership and go back through the
classes in a local group go to the
lessons at a local group and yeah your
act together girl don't look up five
years from now and go I made turn fifty
thousand dollars the last five years and
all it is paying them almost mortgage I
got nothing to show for it
don't do that don't do that don't live
like that anymore life is too short
you've worked too hard to make this kind
of money to be this broke you deserve to
be doing better than this but it's
completely on you to do it and you can
you can do this you got this I know you
can do it if you need some help you call
me back I'm here to coach you
but sometimes part of coaching is
kicking your butt that's what you just
got was a butt kickin did you feel it I
hope you did that was for you because I
care about you this is the Dave Ramsey
show